la route tout si auxerre le quotidien
d'une grande majorité de ces
manifestants en cortège à 20 km/heure
ils protestent contre le prix du
carburant qui plombent leur budget ils
habitent l'accusé en campagne mais
viennent à auxerre tous les jours alors
comme ici à l'entrée de la ville
ils ont décidé d'en bloquer les accès on
a à peu près entre 35 et 40 km à
rapprocher des grandes villes comme
auxerre donc l'impact et ben c'est
direct comme faut faire des grosses
courses quand fallu au médecin parce que
c'est pareil dans les campagnes a plus
de médecin alors fallu aux médecins ces
six mois d'attentes mais le médecin il
est à la grande ville et toutes ces
choses là mais comme on y va on n'a pas
le choix que d'y aller en voiture
géraldine bourgeois elle n'a pas de
gilet jaune mais participe à sa façon au
mouvement
nous sommes à saint sauveur au coeur de
la puiser son salon de coiffure et de
beauté est aujourd'hui gratuit pour les
clients
on n'avait pas forcément envie de se
déplacer pour moi en fait rouler moins
cher c'est bien meilleurs ou les mois
c'est bien aussi
donc voilà rester chez nous et et est
donné en fait à une dimension un peu
plus local à notre action c'était
important pour nous se déplacer l'homme
des problèmes majeurs à la campagne la
première gare est à 40 minutes d'ici en
voiture la plupart habitent de petits
villages ont puisé en arrivant ici j'ai
ressenti le besoin en effet arrivé à
bientôt 25 ans de passer mon permis
parce qu'il est indispensable ici de la
voir et de pouvoir avoir une voiture
pour circuler ça c'est indéniable il ya
juste un bus me semble à toucy qui nous
emmène à auxerre mais ces deux fois par
jour c'est aller le matin le retour de
soins et la voiture indispensable
solidaire des gilet jaune
elle aurait aimé rejoindre les
manifestants comme ici à auxerre mais
désormais tous se demandent si le
mouvement va perdurer ou
[Musique]